look at the WNBA they've been playing in  front of three to 400 people a night for  a quarter of a century  not to mention it's a male subsidized  League we gave you a [ __ ] League  where are all the feminists  that place should be packed with  feminists wearing jerseys slashing their  titties  going [ __ ] nuts like the guys do in  the Upper Deck with their big beard  titties  they are the jumbo try am I doing it  women failed the WNBA ladies ladies name  your top five all-time WNBA players of  all time come on  that's it name five WNBA teams named at  wnbta team in your [ __ ] City you  can't do it  you don't give a [ __ ]  about them they play night in and night  out in front of nobody it's a [ __ ]  tragedy